[музика]
Привіт друзі і дорослі і малеча з вами я
пані Ліда і ведмежатко бо Привіт привіт
Усім минулого разу ми з вами вивчили
літеру є
ось пам'ятаєте
А сьогодні ми вивчимо нову літеру А яку
ви зараз здогадаєтесь самі адже вам буде
підказка ось послухайте є у нього довгі
роги
забирайтеся з дороги
жу-жу-жу гудить дзижчить коли в небі він
летить має крила і 6 рук
буркотливий чорний хто це друзі видає
такі звуки коли летить
вірно це Жук і наша сьогоднішня літери
яку ми з вами будемо вивчати теж подібна
на жучка Подивіться на неї
давайте з вами подзем як жучок як багато
жучків Давайте будемо видавати такі звук
Нумо спробуйте
[музика]
так літера ж і звук
ось такий звук видає жучок і слово жук
починається на літеру ж
А зараз ведмедику Давайте спробуємо з
дітками іти подивися Написати цю літеру
адже вона має паличку яка посередині і
такі лапки з одного боку і з другого
боку Ось і вийшла літера ж як жучок із
лапками
гаразд А зараз послухайте ще одну
загадку
ква-ква-ква вона виводить
позура булькатим очком як журавлика
огледить прикидається
листочком Хто це вона має такий зелений
колір і дуже-дуже не любить журавлів
і робить на болоті
ква-ква-ква
вірно друзі це Жаба і ми з вами складемо
з літер які Ми вже вивчили слово жаба
ж наступна а
наступна літера б і остання а і ми разом
з вами прочитаємо слово яке утворилося
ведмедику давайте разом
[музика]
всі літери цього слова ви вже вивчили і
були величезні молодці гаразд А зараз
наступна загадка
дивний ключ у небі лине не залізний а
пташиний цим ключем в осінній млі мла це
така темрява осіння відлітають
що за пташки
журавлі абсолютно вірно Чому вони летять
ключем вони створюють такий ніби
трикутничок Коли вони летять
Гаразд друзі а зараз ще одна загадка про
тваринку слово яке починається на літеру
ж
довга шия як драбина в чорних плямах
жовта спина
листячко з дерев зриває в холодочку
спочиває
височенне ніби шафа в Африці живе
жирафа вірно молодці ви здогадалися були
уважні А зараз для вас таке буде
завдання ви вже колись його робили
спробуйте знайти слова із літерою ж
зараз на екрані з'являться слова Коли
слово з літерою ж з'являється ви би
піднімаєте пальчик угору пам'ятаєте ми
вже так з вами робили
Нумо до роботи
будьте уважні жаба
Жук
[музика]
горіх
кажан
молодці ліжко
Так Ми піднімаємо пальчик угору ліжко
ножиці
[музика]
чуємо звук Ж молодці сніжинка
і пальчик угору
Жолудь
і знову пальчик угорі І ще одне слово
журавель
молодці друзі А скажіть нам будь ласка а
назва якого кольору починається з літери
ж ми вам підкажемо
якого кольору сонечко
правильно
жовтий А що може бути ще жовтого кольору
може бути жовтий листочок
жовта сукня
жовте каченя А зараз пошукайте навколо
себе щось жовтого кольору А якщо не
знайдете то придумайте що може бути ще
жовтого кольору А ось і наш жук сонечко
ви знаєте чому у нього такий яскравий
колір
тому що він таким чином попереджає мене
їсти не можна Я не смачний так-так і
знаєте жук сонечко дуже корисний жук
тому що він рятує рослинки від маленьких
шкідників від різної тлі і таке інше
раз Друзі А зараз давайте прикрасимо
нашого жучка сонечко різними плямками
але пам'ятаєте які геометричні фігури у
нас для цього використовується ведмедику
ану подивись будь ласка знайди мені
серед цих геометричних фігур квадрат
[музика]
ось
Правильно молодець справді це квадрат
ось ми прикріпимо цей квадратик на
нашого жучка
ось один квадратик в нас є а тепер будь
ласка ведмедику знайди кружечок його
кружечок зною Ось він молодець ведмедику
і покажи будь ласка трикутник
трикутник має три кути я точно це знаю
це така гірко
правильно ось трикутничок
посади будь ласка ведмедику А ми зараз
прикріпимо ці геометричні фігури на
нашого жучка сонечко Отже у нас є один
квадратик один кружечок і один трикутник
Зараз ми добавимо ще один трикутник
та один кружечок
і ще один квадратик Скажіть мені будь
ласка скільки всіх геометричних фігур ми
прикріпили давайте це зробимо разом
ведмедику подивися один два три
чотири п'ять шість шість
геометричних фігур всього У нас є на
нашому жучку сонечко Гаразд вивели
величезні молодці а зараз для вас
завдання
Намалюйте будь ласка жучка сонечко який
має
скільки лапок порахуйте будь ласка
три лапки з однієї сторони
і три лапки з іншої скільки усіх лапок у
жучка
вірно 6 лапок ви намалюєте ось такого
жучка сонечко овальної форми домалюєте
йому 6 лапок і будь ласка Намалюйте йому
Ось такі красиві цяточки у формі різних
геометричних фігур можуть бути
квадратики кружечки і трикутнички ось
таке ваше завдання буде на сьогодні
Ну що ж а наше заняття підійшло до
завершення Сьогодні ми з вами вивчили
літеру ж яка подібна на жучка пам'ятаєте
відгадали багато загадок і повторили
геометричні фігури і також потренувалися
у лічбі ну що ж ведмедику а нам час
прощатись з дітками На все добре До
нових зустрічей па-па
[музика]
Привіт друзі Усім привіт з вами пані
Настя і юстинка моя помічниця давайте з
вами трошечки
порухаємось і розрухаємо наше тіло вам
потрібно вставити на ніжки і зараз ми з
вами зробимо його давайте розберемо як
ми будемо робити рухи перше що ми робимо
ми стаємо на ніжки випрямляємо
нашу спинку так тягнемось маківкою вверх
Окей Ну і ми вже з вами колись робили
цей рух ми витягуємо ручки через сторону
вверх робимо вдих і робимо такий
бананчик чудово тепер коли ми будемо
робити видих беручки опускаємо
фух і опускаємо самі і намагаємось
доторкнутися до наших пальчиків до землі
або до землі Так попереду добре І далі
ми будемо ніжками підходити назад
ручками теж можна трошки вперед пройтись
і будемо робити таку гірку або собачку
чудово тепер
прогинаємо нашу спинку це буде собачка
мордочкою вверх
тягнемось голівкою рахуваємо плечик Я
навпаки намагаємось виштовхнути їх
Чудово А тепер вертаємось назад Ось так
добре
Тепер нам потрібно буде підняти одну
ніжку вгору Давайте спробуємо є
молодці і тепер цю ніжку переводимо
вперед так далеко-далеко вперед
Чудово Ну і тепер нам потрібно піднятися
Трошки так чудово стоїмо
є а тепер ніжку яка в нас позаду
наближаємо Ось так стаємо рівненько
робимо вдих
і види
Чудово Ну і тепер повторюємо все з іншою
ногою так само робимо вдих
стаємо в бананчик або в ракету ракету та
видих опускаємо ручки
ручки трошечки крокують вперед аніжки
відходять назад
стоїмо в собачці мордочкою вниз і
прогинаємось собачкою мордочкою вгору
Чудово
А тепер знов вертаємось собачку
мордочкою вниз і вже тепер піднімаємо
іншу ногу Вверх і ось так пустуємо один
два три чотири п'ять чудово переводимо
ніжку вперед
Ага і стоїмо Ось так можна тут до речі
теж спробувати зробити ракету є молодець
чудово Я сподіваюся щоб наші глядачів
теж так класно виходить
опускаємо і стаємо рівненько робимо вдих
і види
і ще один вдих
і
чудово тепер тягнемось однією ручкою
вгору потягнулись
А тепер іншою
потягнулися вгору чудово тепер можна
відійти трошечки назад ми витягуємо наші
ручки Вверх і тепер
нахиляємось вперед Наче хтось Нас тягне
за ручки нога чудово намагаємось нашу
спинку ще можна трошки а ручки оп вверх
чудово і намагаємось тримати нашу спинку
рівно і опускаємось вниз
і піднімаємось вгору знову вдих
і види
х чудово молодці Ви дуже гарно
справились
па-па
[музика]